I want to see the footage man well this
is interesting where to just finish the
glad that you documented it cuz this
could be like some yeah you're making
all the people listening sound like they
want to see it now
well we'll post it without the audio
like just an Instagram clip of 15
seconds of your rage guys how about that
yeah you could do that I don't mind I
don't mind that but the audio oh maybe
have some like some like horn likes
music yeah yeah yeah art there yeah yeah
like jaws like that don't worry the
cameras there they were fighting in here
no that was some good [ __ ] too that was
like the he was like he kept I can hear
pokey his Pokemon you know he's good at
that huh he's a master at that
especially with me he knows everything
now and then he frames his story when he
tells the story back to somebody he
frames it so that he he looks good yeah
that's not you that's your problem
that's not me that's your problem
I feel bad for the state your problem
the classic huh I've cried to you
several times over the same thing I
don't know how you do it and you're like
come on come on it's okay yeah yeah I
forgot it was like a getting you know
splash the face with cold water like
whoa that has been there yeah I just
haven't felt that in a while yeah yeah
no I mean I love you missed a good one
George yeah this one man always here for
like the crazy one he's the most calm
that would just you know just off the
record that would never happen on the
Steve Wiebe show professional I do the
opposite I never put anyone on blast
yeah I'm optimist it I like pre-screen
I'm like hey if I is it cool if I bring
this up you're also a fun machine on and
then yeah cuz I that's I don't want to
do the opposite I don't want to ever
make anyone feel that ever mm-hmm cuz I
know how feel your dad I know how it
feels
to be honest II I was it was like a bad
dream like when he said it I was like I
couldn't believe you did not yes what
your face look like I was at rosing it's
like my mind no you look like you were
betrayed did you just say
you know to me I saw betrayal yeah yeah
Thrones like like some Joffrey like like
Littlefinger being like yeah yeah it was
like that type of she found out it was
it evident on my face yeah I almost
thought I felt bad for you cuz I felt
like you and when you touched her heart
yeah yeah touch my yeah yeah I affected
me I was like yeah I'm gonna go bake a
cake
no but but I have to thank you you did
you were like you knew right away you're
like hitting him what's not talking
about good everybody talked about yeah
we all right yeah fall 2018 to stay
tuned just really quick with kalila just
say your New Year's resolution really
quick oh my is to stop thinking that I'm
on time when I'm not on time being ten
minutes late to everything to all things
twenty minutes late and having Albert
wait for me downstairs we're patient for
a ten is not cool on time means you're
15 minutes early I'll do the same thing
because I've been doing that towards
that of the year did you already say
yours
why was kind of the well I guess didn't
say it but kind of the I guess more
discipline in all aspects of my life so
even the whole passive-aggressive thing
he has really being more self-aware when
I'm talking to people and how I react to
things that I may be uncomfortable for
me you stay in the pocket and not walk
away and resort to my it's very hard I'm
really starting to realize there's
nothing more commendable than someone
feeling conflicted but staying to talk
about it and saying you know what let's
hash this [ __ ] out right now cuz I feel
like I'm not good at it but you are no
you are doing like every time we've ever
talked about serious stuff like we've
you know you've always been able to like
articulate your feelings well but maybe
it's different in relationships yeah
because you see the other person hurting
for like there's not an understanding
there then it's like I don't want that
person to feel kind of like you guys
like I wouldn't want to do that so I
wouldn't do that and I know you would
but if I did but yeah it takes a
specific type of person to do that no
but it does it does yeah I mean do you
think people don't do that your brother
lives with no consequence like not no
consequence like there's a thing where
he he which is him like his life is he's
so unblocked mailable because he's put
it all out there already
yeah but that's
we're not yeah that's you there's other
people different experiences unlike you
that's just you that's your experience
other you have to like be empathetic
towards other people's situations that's
all but I think that he needed to hear
it from you and I think that things will
change cool and also you're vegetarian
now I know just for the month of January
I need you guys support I am doing rice
vegetarians my second day I like that I
like that how about this can we all do
this collectively like we go hiking more
do something every day Steve or
physically well I need to remind myself
that what's so fun Steve and I went
hiking oh wait I wanna yeah we loved it
what happened no we went hiking and we
got lost
when we got locked in oh yeah and Steve
had to like Jimmy engage and like Jimmy
yes you fine but you know what you know
what my dream is and this is this is
real [ __ ] I would love for a family hike
no I would love for him to start being
more physically healthy yeah I'm trying
we're trying this another podcast for
Bobby said you know we're handy dick but
that's never gonna happen where he he
does some health decisions make it a
family yeah he says that he wants to do
this vegetarian thing with me and I'm
like I just prepare his meals and that's
it I do
end of story for him I cook dinner for
him if we have del Taco we had [ __ ]
brisket or we do we have the worst we
ain't worth [ __ ] I'm just letting you
know ain't the worst [ __ ] [ __ ] there
yeah the worst [ __ ] sorry happy new year
everyone you're sorry come back here
make sure you play make sure your
stomach hurt make sure you follow us on
Tiger Valley on Instagram at Tiger belly
on Twitter at the tiger belly and emos
any questions or unhelpful advice at the
Tiger belly at gmail.com see you guys
next week oh and then also Tiger Billy's
got a store they've got a new oh thank
you find the shirt they have a new blue
shirt out and a sticker pack
oh yeah there's only 10 shirts left
there's still more sticker packs and now
with that thing I merchandise for 2018
guys meanwhile another resolution is
that we'll be getting more merch out to
you guys and they'll be more frequent so
it won't be these long gaps
you'll see stuff more so there's more
stuff coming our and Stevie would be
merch coming in yes maybe something and
you have a patreon yeah oh yes my own
money that guy
on Stevie we V yeah just so he could
keep doing it yeah money and then banned
can't buy that little ray buy any of the
album's do it donate that [ __ ]
all of a by all day out it all goes to
charities are do it
[Music]